over the past year i have endured dozens
of
woke commercials i have tried to guess
what product these woke companies are
actually trying to sell the companies
spent millions of dollars trying to out
virtue signal one another
ah however that is nothing compared to
the millions and millions and millions
in tax dollars governments around the
world spend on woke psa commercials
of their own that is what we'll be
watching today these psas i will not
have to guess what they are selling
this is this is far more important today
i will determine
once and for all which country hates
racism the most
my producer uncovered a few government
sponsored youtube channels
i will review these psas try against the
country and
ultimately i will determine who has
tried the hardest
to end racism once and for all let's get
started
allow me thank you
probably not friends
what i do well i mean it's uh
obviously some place in the anglosphere
so it's either the
uk south africa or uh
australia or new zealand um
i i'm really confused it's not just that
i'm trying to guess the
country i just i don't get the
commercial it was kind of
abrupt and weird and eerie and i don't
totally get the message i'm going to say
australia australian human rights
commission all right i mean the accent
it was really it was either you know
australia new zealand those accents
sound almost exactly the same
and then south africa is like isidirique
which is like a little bit different so
okay that's good
that in a thousand let's go to the next
one i'm calling on every one of my
fellow
to help support a very important cause
racism needs your help to survive
you may not be in a position to give
much to racism
but whatever you feel comfortable giving
will make a huge difference
you don't have to be a full-on racist
just being a tiny bit racist is enough
a smile a cheeky giggle even a simple
not in agreement
it all adds up and it gives others the
message that it's okay
frequently asked questions about racism
but i'm not a real racist can i still
help of course
even if you don't come from a racist
background that's okay being a bit
racist is super easy
what's in it for me uh nothing there's
no benefit whatsoever to being racist
but ask yourself
what if everyone stopped giving to
racism what kind of future would that be
for our children
if i only give a little bit will it even
make a difference not to you
no but to the people receiving the
racism they'll be getting hundreds of
small bits
every day so it will add up it will be
noticed
how do i show my support you might not
want to wear a t-shirt that says how
much of a racist you are
no thanks i'm racist on the inside
but you can laugh at racist comments it
does the same thing
[Music]
remember the only thing that can keep
racism alive
and help it grow is feeding it nurturing
it
and that's where you come in will you
help it flourish
what will you give to racism so
before we get into which country this is
again obviously in the anglosphere
he says that racism doesn't get
anything for the racist like there's no
benefit to the racist for being racist
isn't that the opposite of the point
that the left always makes doesn't the
left always say
whites are all racist and they have
privilege
because of this and what we need to do
is give up that privilege
so beca and then we'll be anti-racist so
how is it that racism gets you all these
like privileges and things
but also there's no privilege to that
that doesn't make a lot of sense
uh well it's either the uk
or i guess south africa i don't think
that there would be another
this could be new zealand uh i'm gonna
say
i'm really torn between new zealand and
south africa it's also kind of low
budget
so i'm gonna i'm leaning a little bit
more like new zealand that's kind of
more far-flung but i'm gonna say
south africa new zealand uh yeah i
couldn't
it's hard because those those accents
are both like really kind of weird
british accents okay well that's too bad
i guess i don't get partial credit for
that do i nope yeah i should have known
because it's just so
so low budget
[Music]
okay so two anglo countries
both very very concerned about racism
let's try for the third one
oh this one's this is more than race and
we've got the trans and the
dear homophobes racists bigots
transphobes and disables
there are things this country doesn't
welcome we don't welcome you
attacking people because of their
religion where they're from
or the color of their skin we don't
welcome you abusing
and bullying disabled people we don't
welcome threatening gay
lesbian or transgender people with
verbal
or physical abuse
haters are not going to hate you that's
why if we see anything
we're calling the police we believe
in acceptance and it's time you accept
that
so so uh i'm
just on the accent that's too bad i
should have swapped the last two i'm
gonna say this one was
south africa
scotland really because i once heard a
comedian say
that the south african accent was it was
just the london accent played backwards
on a record player i can't help but
notice here
it's only white countries pushing this
sort of
stuff isn't it like you don't you don't
see a lot of anti-racism psas from china
do you
you do the only the only psas on race
that you would see in china
is about how terrible the uyghurs are
and why they need to commit genocide
against them which is the actual
policy of the chinese government
culturally there are different
norms at each country and they their
leaders are expected to follow
i was sort of waiting for a french psa
or something but then i kind of forgot
the french actually are
sort of racist you know the french are
sort of like oh
i mean they're racist against everybody
they're like i i was in italy once and i
met a french person and they're sort of
like oh
oh no i do not want to talk to you but
it was obviously in french
maybe that says something more
like a nicer thing about people in the
anglosphere maybe
bear with me i know this is shocking
maybe people living in the west
and specifically in the anglosphere
maybe they're not the most
racist people in the world maybe they're
the least racist
people ever in the whole history
of the world but the least racist of the
least racist countries that's got to go
to australia
because the the second one from new
zealand
that one made really weird sort of
contradictory arguments that wasn't very
persuasive they didn't they didn't have
their heart and soul in it
the third one from scotland it didn't
even really care that much about racism
it was all
talking about trans and this and that so
that one doesn't count
homophobes uh australia that was that
was like a
threat you know they're all just getting
on the elevator
and the guy doesn't leap down to push
the button by the way whenever the doors
are closing on an elevator and someone
is running to catch it
every person in the elevator is pushing
the closed button that's all that ever
happens regardless of race or whatever
but then you know the ominous music and
they're both staring at him like listen
buddy
you better not be racist anymore so i'm
gonna have to give that award to
australia well done australia what do i
know i'm only battin
333 please send in other videos that you
would like me to review in the comment
section
i'll try to do better next time
[Music]
[Music]
you